hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we will be
looking at a track called the mortimer
trap it derives from the roy Lopez
opening and the Berlin defense we'll go
ahead and get into it starts with pawn
to e4 pawn e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
defending this pawn is being attacked
Bishop to b5 this is the roy lopez
opening Knight to f6 this is the berlin
defense and from here white moves d3 now
obviously every game you play you're not
going to see you white move pawn to d3
but if you do play the berlin defense
and you see pawn to d3 then you can try
out the mortimer trap and mortimer trap
looks like this it's Knight to e7
basically giving up this pawn on e5 as a
trap and if white takes it we're going
to go ahead and look at what happens
obviously this Knight was defending our
pawn on e5 so now it's definitely
hanging y can come in and capture this
knight or excuse me this pawn on e5 and
then we can simply play the move pawn to
c6 now if he moves his Bishop anywhere
he moves it to a6 obviously we'll take
it with our pawn if he moves it to
excuse me c4 then we can simply bring
our Queen to a5 check and we're forking
the night here on e5 now if he moves his
Bishop to a4 we can simply bring our
Queen to a5 and check and forth both the
bishop and the knight we have our choice
so White's best move in this case is
actually to bring his Knight to c4
attacking this a5 score so we can't put
our Queen there now a lot of people will
say yeah but he's gonna lose his bishop
anyway well right away he can't cuz if
we get greedy and try to take his Bishop
right away on b5 then he can simply
bring his Knight to d6 and checkmate we
lose not very good so from here what
we're actually going to play instead of
capturing right away is we need to make
first we need to defend against the
smothered mate checkmate from Knight to
d6 we're going to bring our pawn to
these six and again we're still
attacking the bishop on b5 so he's going
to have to move it obviously you can't
move it to a6 so his only move is to
bring it back to a5 and if he does that
then we can simply bring our pawn to b5
and we're attacking now both pieces and
he's going to end up losing one of them
and wil will subsequently be up in
material so although I thought he was
getting a free pawn on e5 instead he's
going to be
down in material so hope you guys enjoy
this trap it's pretty simple and
straightforward but if you do play the
Berlin defense and you see the d3 move a
lot of times you'll see just White
Castle but if you do see the 3 d3 move
you can go ahead and try out the more -
more trap that we talked about today so
hope everyone enjoyed if you haven't
already please subscribe and I'll see
you guys next video thanks for watching